today
javascript is the most popular language
in the world
why by many measures why do you think
that is
is it is there some fundamental ideas
that you've already spoke to a little
bit
sort of broader that you think it's the
most popular language in the world so i
think i did
you know by doing first-class functions
and
taking the the good parts of the c
operator hierarchy and just
keeping things um simple enough maybe it
could have been simpler but
i had had to make it look like java and
interoperate with java
that there was uh you know inherent
goodness and aristotelian quality there
and people perceive that
even through all the quirks and warts
and then over time working on it with
the standards body working on it
not only in is a core language but in
the context of
html5 making the browser better
listening to developers
thinking about this is something that
nick thompson wrote nicely about
on hacker news i was very flattered he
said java was this thing where
the experts were writing the code and it
was compiled you had to declare all your
types and
some didn't really give a damn about you
know the
average programmer who wanted to build
real web apps dynamic things
and i was in there meanwhile doing a you
know a bunch of people's jobs making
javascript
survive those early years when it was
kind of touch and go right
javascript was considered mickey mouse
language it was for annoyances like the
scrolling text at the bottom of the
browser in the status bar
but i kept listening to developers
working with them and trying to make
it run in that single threaded event
loop in a useful way and i think that
forged something that people have come
to love now you don't
always love you know the best thing
right i talked about
shakespeare sonnet about um
my mistress eyes or nothing like the sun
or you know the scene from uh
josh whedon's film uh serenity at the
end where the actual
piece and the score by david newman is
called love where uh
the met captain mal is teaching uh river
tam about how to pilot the ship and
she's a super genius super soldier so he
knows how to do it already
and he's he's basically talking about
how you have to love the ship because if
you don't it's going to kill you
and then the piece falls off the ship
it's kind of like javascript
yeah i love it you have to love it
because now people say
we're stuck with it because it got this
priority in place but there's love
underpinning that and
actually the listening to developers
that's kind of beautiful there's uh
most successful products in this world
with all the messes with all the flaws
perhaps the flaws themselves are actual
features but that's a whole nother
that's a discussion about love but
underneath it there's something that
just
connects with people and it has to keep
connecting if javascript kind of went
off in this
people sometimes complain about es6 oh
you put classes in javascript i hate
classes you know you've ruined it
but it's it's not true it's a dynamic
language small talk had
classes um python has classes um
there are lots of list variants that
have classy systems um
comment list so you know people
who don't reject it based on some sort
of fashion
judgment do use it and do
interact with the standards body the
standards body is competing browser
vendors mainly but also
now big companies that use javascript
heavily the paypals and the
other such companies uh salesforce and
they have to cater to web developers
they have to hire
developers who know javascript they have
to keep
their engines up to the latest standard
and this creates all this sort of
social structure around javascript that
is unusual i mean
you get c plus plus buffs that follow
the inner workings of you know c
plus plus what is it now 21 something i
don't know
i've lost track but it's it's a more
rarefied group it's more like the old
language you know
gray hairs uh whereas javascript is a
younger and
more you know vibrant large crowd
there's a community feel to it
there's a echoes perhaps i don't want to
draw too many
similarities maybe you can comment on it
there's a
c plus is like wall street and the
javascript is like wall street bets
from the recent events it's like there's
a chaotic community walk
and there's some power from that
distributed crowd of
people that it's absolutely it's more
demotic it's more of the people
uh it lets people in without requiring
these credentials i remember
in the late 90s into the naughties
people were all getting java credentials
and i knew people
um and friends knew people who became
jealous programmers and you knew they
really should have been like
nature guides or pilots they hated
programming but they thought
i got to make money
you